about Romania which was a country as you
just said which was basically they're
the hardest version of communism even in
the 1980s and I just wonder you know
maybe this could be a good topic for
future scholars and students of the you
know issue to compare this to countries
like Romanian hunger which makes this
very striking outcome that everything is
absolutely different you know and and
demise option the mud version of
illustration or the attitude towers
illustration is the same you know
Hungary was the softest version of
communism you know as opposed to the
hardest version in Romania the
transition itself was the softest
version I mean the most civilized most
negotiated one in Hungary in a day 88
1889 well as opposed to Romania where
the bloody revolution happiness as you
just said you know so I'm still as far
as we come to obsession it's very very
very similar approach by the political
elite and of course you know it's beyond
the scope of this conference is too bad
there is nobody from Hungary and as an
expert to talk about that you know maybe
they buy the real causes of that but
actually that's all I think it's the
very interesting you know topic for for
comparison so now the floor is open till
common so please come to the microphone
questions to object to mind one comment
regarding of custom skis representation
well my question refers to the new law
in Czech Republic regarding the access
to the secret police files new
relatively new law as far as I know it
was passed in 2004 and to my knowledge
with law gives the unlimited access to
these files basically everyone has can
get the file of everyone else without
any restrictions and probably this is
the most liberal the most open
regulation in all the countries of misty
in all the posthumous countries how does
the system work in practice did it
provoke a lot of public interest and the
second question is
I heard that the new institution in the
Czech Republic is being created which
would the deal with the Communists
passed a similar one to the Polish
institute of national remembrance could
you tell us something about this new
undertaking and my comment to a circus
Adamski's speeches basically I disagree
with many you're there are many
statements regarding the politics of
history but I will speak about it after
lunch so I will not elaborate too much
right now I only want to say that I
can't agree with your statement but only
now for the first time the commemoration
of katyn massacre was organized with the
participation of the president I would
remind you that in the 90s where war
cemeteries were opened in a mid Noah
cutting car goof balls places where
Polish officers were buried and a lot of
public coverage was given to to the
ceremonies a Polish President took part
in viscera most not in a very dignified
way as we know who president fashion
have ski but this is a different story
when a private TV covered his behavior
and public public TV there are always
problems with public TV all engines even
when did not show my present position
who let's say we have not in a perfect
perfect way where another example a
monument was erected in also in the 90s
devoted to both poles who were deported
to the east during the war and who were
murdered by the Soviets and every year
public celebrations are organized at
this monument with a participation of
the higher-ranked politician so I think
what the reality is again more
complicated
okay so the first question but in fact
de also that by yourself so that's true
so there is since i think 205 there is a
valid law about archives and it really
gives an completely unlimited access to
all documents not only of state security
but of Communist Party and other
organizations of the old regime without
any restrictions even without the
protection of personal data so otherwise
in check archives author is a great
right white protection of personal data
but it doesn't apply for this kind of
documents in fact there was a certain
development I would say that was a
gradual development 97 or something like
that there was a an act which made
access to your own files so you could
you could see your own files but then it
changed and now already really anything
is open there was that quite a hot
discussion something like two years ago
and it especially the focus most on the
protection of personal data especially
especially in documents of victims of of
persecution of state security but so
there was even a petition signed by
historians and former dissidents and so
on and as far as i know some some
members of parliament made a question
for Constitutional Court if this is and
but until today the core didn't didn't
decide about about it so by the use of
this of this unlimited access is as I
say rather now it's especially if you if
you look on the medic check media it's
every two weeks another another affair
with the famous someone but but usually
it's it's really focus is on actors
singers sportsmen some some some
previous politicians but that it seems
to me that
practices data just the the journalistic
just take the name and and they make a
story about it and it's I would say more
business oh it's have had titles with
they send this was involved with with
state security and so on but it's really
not a serious approach about the modern
period yeah so one thing can be the
other thing yes that there was there was
a log last night with this spring about
the establishment since I mean january
or februari next year of the new new
institution originally it had been
called institute of national remembrance
but then after some discussions they
changed the name into the institute for
the study of totalitarian regimes or
something like that so basically i think
it delivers with the polish example so
the one task of the Institute will be to
take over the documents of all not only
state security but other repressor
repressive forces of the of the old
regime but but so it will be an archive
a special archive and the other thing
will be that that the task will be to
organize research publications general
to inform educate and inform the
societies or something like the polish
case but that still it's no no no not at
all no there is still this office for
investigation and documentation it still
exists so it was deprived of its
documentation part so all so the old
office for investigation and
documentation of the crimes of communist
era established 1993 was
now it still exists that but the
documentation part went over to this new
Institute it still doesn't exist but
it's more or less the same people right
now the archive of the Ministry of
interiors of something like 90 people
who work for the office of Investigation
and documentation were brought to the
archive of the Ministry of Interior and
it's in with intention that they will
work within this new institution and and
the the old office as a much small small
institution will work on perfect
prosecution persecution and yeah this
this new new Institute will be just
archives and and education and research
and and so long so this is quite quite
interesting that the next I think day
after tomorrow this wednesday the Senate
will will vote for the something like
this dipolog you in here instead famine
similar way so clever BF a board I don't
know exactly the name of the boards or
with with 77 / census of the Senate will
will elect this port and and this board
were played definitely very important
part in in just supervision over the
Institute and my opinion also it will
play a role in competition for director
of the of the new Institute and so on so
we'll see no but it was quite quite hot
discussion in amateur historian and
archivist and so on and I think the most
important factor in the decision to to
create this institution where elections
parliamentary elections 2006 with with
majority a slight one but majority for
civic Democratic Party and and other
party sent so
and this disa fork or somehow connected
with sending them of democratic parties
I didn't there was I think those are
Santa's neither when I I stress that of
course the right is more complicated and
all these events i mentioned were
commemorated before so i agree with you
but I think also that there was a really
qualitative change in recent years and I
think everybody who really observed this
as a most have to acknowledge it yeah
just to mention that that you know just
this this guest of a president kaczynski
to promote the officer cute in in
cutting you know it's very simple but
very moving gaastra and that all the
names of the victim who were an in depth
in the publicly and so you know for me
is astonishing am I said that no polish
historian yeah wrote a book about it
yeah the film about Catanese might just
wow yeah so this is the questions why by
the made this FEMA's or his father was
yeah but not what was the monographie
yeah yeah there were many yeah this many
work was done about battery this is the
same like you know is the with the walls
arise of course there was a monument and
so but then but the museum was opened up
2004 yeah and and really I am myself
will astonish how how how big is the
change how deep is the change the idea
to give to give the order to the people
from solid on ashore and neglected like
like like like just a volunteer
knowledge yeah besides all we can call
about the role
but you know it's a generally you cannot
say it didn't change anything now it has
a really a change as a deeply and the
question which is now as open up this is
the question if the Republic of life
will pursue this career on this politic
in the future of of the of it would be a
small and subtle changes of priorities
you know because this is the question
how do you do and so what do you do with
it with this stuff I must one of the
world the book of the walls arise
including by Polish assorted book by
biology it was published in in German
but with what a strange conclusion in
the end i might say Leah and because he
described this so probably what is the
more acceptable for German sizes are
very irrational and and and so on on the
end is that political conclusions is use
as a legitimation from the round table
room negotiation you know you have to
avoid this tragedy and so on and so so
it's ready so there's no disagreement I
think boom in between us I I do it was
not my intention to say that it was
nothing done and I appreciate the work
of the people all these monuments but
still I will insist on it that that that
it as a what happened as a 23 years or
four years ago it's a significant change
in the in this attitude to the children
to the National pass and so we move this
as a poisonous as you know that the dead
did such a that also rising was
commemorated last year first are not
only in water yeah so it's a it's a very
yes oh all that we have you know that
now now this is the idea to build up
museum of national history and I was cup
of months ago in battery foundation and
we had always to differ defended this
you know given this idea because they
are still among as the people of say
okay what is the politics of this earth
is not it is not in competence of state
you know and you look around you are in
the am living in German you don't know
what this crew to approach to school to
visits you know you know how many the
state through foundation and so unless
in the history and the politics of
history you know not in probably not in
negative attitude but just to talk to
preserved as a memory such them so once
again i would say you cannot deny that
it's something that's change and we will
see what will happen in future my
question is in what extent it is a
typical for the circle of Czechoslovak
the dissidents this approach is a
typical or not and the the second
question is addressing to our Germans
because let's say a maid to 82 years ago
probably I'm not sure Klaus Bachmann
book the launch site of the fetch right
right how the Germans
change their national character was
published in Polish and the main phases
of this book is that the contemporary
politics of history in Germany is based
on a civic parody on the notion like
like democracy human rights pluralist
and and so on and my question is is
there any alternative for this approach
in Germany I mean it politics of history
and dealing with paths thank you yes I I
would say this is quite typical for the
mainstream of the of the descent of
charter 77 of course they were whatever
it was different they were different
groups and different opinion so
especially the younger people and much
more radical opponents of the communist
regime were more and more important in
late 80s wouldn't agree with this but
more or less what other several times
said about the illustration lon I would
say would be typical especially for
those who were formerly communist and
were expelled from the party after 68
which was not the case of other other
never was matter of the Communist Party
man yes I would say this is more or less
typical but but of course there are a
variety of different in it professor Wes
would you like to comment or mini okay
because I really don't know the book
that I just heard that he probably was
only published in Polish so I mean I
have not heard of hidden in the other
German sitting here saying polish so I'm
sorry that I have to pass up no see I
said something about Klaus battlin
because i was in many discussion with
him or some battery foundation and he's
he left Germany 20 years ago 15 years
ago she she he lives permanently he
lives memantine poor and I think his is
most of immigrants as of his picture of
German is this a picture of Germany
vision of Germany I think you know
obsolete in in a way you know because he
and on the other hand he's really he is
influential in porn he's not very known
in Germany this is why you don't know
his name because he indeed and sometimes
I I in a discussion with I saw that many
Polish intellectuals are really in
helpless because they have no already
knowledge to discuss with him here so he
once I I was at the discussion on he
talking about German attitude to the
Orange Revolution in Ukraine according
to me as a totally wrong here battery
you know so I general say it's it's so
true you can I make the composite this
is like you not to hear about
registration proposal Elster you learn
something but he also hands and it's
one-sided yeah and and look I have here
two very important publication recently
saw one is from Edgar occurred for
Mozgov of us finding the the linear
Republicans fat around yeah the renal
Republican escada not really it is about
new German poetry of this as a quiet
it's not it's not it is not combined
with you know it's see
when Ernest Nationals acidic Nationals
they combine this with with European 82
told an answer but they said from polish
German German relations a little
complicated but it is the other is a
speciality noise doctrine2 physiognomy
the marina Republic and here you have a
such a article his address Babu stemetil
marker self-conscious middle power by
Herod moon Clarissa you know reading
German political scientist or you have a
article about new patriotism about her
battery monument and so so this this
doesn't make the opinion by Backman
totally wrong because of course it's not
back to the thirties but it is not you
know but it's not fair fastens but it is
most fun fun fun Harbor Mars because
it's gone yeah it's gone yeah everything
and important the people who
rediscovered the concept of
professionals part of your business is
like wisps postmodern is at the time and
which is already passed yeah so this is
often so and this is why our discussion
answer also about German culture we are
very divided in Poland about this stuff
because many people just cannot accept
the fact that something change you can
see this you please go to bomb a walk
through bomb and then go to barina
walkthrough supermarine and the center
buried and that you noticed a difficult
can I say something anyway also i don't
know the book particular now that they
have a little bit more background I
think it has to do with generations you
know if he left Germany 20 years ago
then you know he has a vision of Germany
of 20 years ago I also say and of course
you know I I mean I'm not a 68 person
i'm not i'm just a little bit too young
but I was heavily influenced by it you
know and I got my degree in Germany and
so on but I also think that this this
development after nineteen ninety toward
more you know self-assured
middle power I think it's a healthy one
you know you cannot live forever being a
central power in Europe and not be
involved I mean you know so in that
sense I think good to me and you may say
you know this is my you know my German
perspective but to me it was overdue to
move toward you know a more active
foreign policy and to create some sense
of patriotism for particularly younger
generations because you know they cannot
live forever with this I mean they live
with the legacy but i think you know to
me it doesn't exclude the other i mean
you can be aware of your past it can be
part of your national consciousness and
you can still be proud to be German
which 20 or 30 years ago was impossible
you know so I think that you know that
sounds like very much agree to do days
and there's a change you know I may see
this change may be more positive than
than some others you know because I have
not you know I have not seen it as a you
know as a new nasty nationalism other
than a few skinheads but you know they
exist unfortunately but but they are not
domains not the mainstream Thank You Man
soon we have one more question picking
up the german-polish issue and I'll
maybe still caught in the Cold War and
hopefully it's totally innocuous my
observation but when you walk from the
railroad station in the 80s to the trip
to the center of the city of dis old or
if there was I deutsches aust house I
can understand a museum like that in
disel dork but I can't quite get
comfortable with the idea there's a
sleazy she's museum in girl it's in rump
chalazion so to say and a poem inicia
museum in graphs loud in rump pomerania
it seems to be at least symbolically
sort of a step in the wrong direction as
innocent as it might be and under the
circumstances of Europe now hardly
anything to be concerned about but it's
just a symbolic a symbol there that
needed an observation again you know I'm
but this is what in my personal opinion
if it were accompanied by new claims on
all territory on nationalism then I
would be very much bothered by it but as
a commemoration of Germany's history I
mean it was part of Germany at some
point and you cannot ignore that pass I
mean you know I'm in history I mean we
we need to look at all aspects of
history and we cannot just exclude
certain parts of it because they are
politically not correct or advantageous
I mean I think it's it's about how you
do it I think it's at least as important
and I think you know that's again part
of however you want to call it about the
normalization to history or broadening
of history in Germany that that you know
that that everybody of course in Germany
was a maybe not everybody but people who
are aware that certain parts of the
history were not discussed you know
initially it was the Nazi past and then
later there were other parts because it
was not politically correct and I think
now we are coming toward you know a more
balanced you hopefully and as I said
it's not so much that it that there is a
history museum but I would have to see
whether what they present bothers me you
know i mean it's the content of the
museum and how they how they presented
you know if they presented as part of
history that is past is done then I
don't have any problems if they you know
pursue it as an agenda of of people who
were expelled then then I would be very
much father by it you know so
yeah but I think that has other reasons
yeah yeah I think that this I see this
small dialect Oh Carly so that's that
means that on one hand I agree with you
that there are some inevitable
tendencies which are now when I talk
with my students it is it would be
irrational to say now to you know you
are guilty or your so this is a kind of
new patriotic sin yeah they are very
proud and on the on the achievement
Democratic achievement and then so what
always what illegal Elite elite concerns
me is a very uncritical attitude no okay
you know I two weeks ago I had a
discussion with my students about the
doors about concept of liberal democracy
and I we talk about John Rawls and I
asked them his Republic Federal Republic
just country and they say yes yeah so
it's a very yellow is a great
achievement when I if I when I asked
this this question to my asthma my
polish students they would be say okay
now now said Republican and so they
identified very very strong this is
there as well and they became sometimes
they are very uncritical so they
identify for instance European position
with own position of the own government
so socially refusal to discuss to
discuss in Germany about the voting
system in European Union it's a it's not
only the political level you know but
also you know on the level of academia
and then the next the problem is they
say maybe the necklace that we for
Easter obedience dead war ended 89 so
because we are affected by the war our
generation so for us it's a four-post is
very
cultural to to realize in a way in this
new gem apotheosis is based on them you
know that the Nazi past is it's not
forgotten but it is in a way it's a
closed yeah and it is very difficult to
close the past the second one war in
important because we just started the
discussion and when we open up the
Museum of German of the wall so rising
it said it's annoying you know because
because on one hand you have to accept I
was in the conference then as a with the
German youth and they have to accept
this but on the other hand it's a its
elite imitating because this means the
poles are back in the history in in this
Keystone and why to build this up so so
there's a kind of you know we are in
different epoch then they said of course
they are in German and they're different
Germans they are not honoring you know
the difference of course there are men
is there they're conservative German the
nationalist German they are still a
member of parliament the country drink
from as I said deutsches reich still
exist in the kissa Member of Parliament
said in the former border even you know
the body you just remembered German
accepted the Polish board in the Western
borden 1990 yeah so it's it's not fun
and such a I don't believe that the
flower Steinbach and so and so so I
would say days also serve such a kind is
such a kind of reaction so and and now
there's the problem because when I say
some of the changes are inevitable and
the problem is how Germany this new
Germany what this young generation would
do with this you know with this new self
confidence
and this is why why is this interesting
to look at it and Toto Toto see I I
wanted not to say that's in there in
this polish German because it's
interesting because you know Jewish
Jewish German relation are not affected
by it why not because they're good yeah
this is a dogma that you cannot you
cannot you know it cannot in public talk
to make impression you relativize this
young because we are finished as a
politician but polish German cases much
more complicated because posters war 39
was considered actually vollmer war you
know it was something yeah yes yes yes
yeah it's a steel classic war that the
total war started as 441 the first book
published about the very MUC crimes in
Poland ok ok yeah yeah I just wanted to
say that the first book about this about
this you know royal of their marking in
Polish in Poland in the war 39 was
published two years ago even if you know
the German historiography would think
you know it is nothing this everything
cover the study but they are really in
this respect in there in this in the
attitude to Central Europe and
especially elite to Czechoslovakia
because just la vecchia you know
politicians lavaca in the vent position
than the other countries because we are
on their site of a lion on the side
other other people and in Poland or
portable occupation was very bitter
thing ok thank you very much but John
can we have one more short comment or
maybe Justin doesn't yeah yeah ah just
short short comment and short question
comment is about the I mean about the
discussion we are having today it seems
its discussion about what what German or
poles or others think about their
history is not about that it's about
what our nation's would like to be in
the future and the discussion we are
witnessing in Germany and also we
started the same kind of the discussion
in poland recently it's about what we
think about ourselves what we think
about our role in europe what we think
about our future whether our nation's as
the nation's we would like to be small
medium sized or big European nations so
this is the common the the question is
are to our panelists what would you
think until not to be answered today but
what I'm what would you point as as as
the reason for the similar result in
terms of illustration let's say
procedures result in our countries
despite the very different point of of
the beginning because in 99 1990 I dare
to say that in Central European State
it's in transformation we had just two
personalities really independent from
the communist past prime minister antal
in Hungary and Havel the present in
Czechoslovakia even not valenza wins his
uncertain past and reliance on in indy
compromise with weather with communists
and on the other hand we had Romania we
had other gradual state of affairs and
the result is similar it means that
probably they are the way to protect
secret collaborators is so good in any
of those every of those cases that it is
possible to defend them even today in
every country and the result is similar
so think about the reasons well thank
you very much and i think is a good glue
and i would like to thank for the panel
is no for the you know really
stimulating papers and for all of you
for coming today and then we are going
to lunch and then we will resume at
two-thirty thank you very much